this episode is brought to you by you
need a budget what is you need a budget
you need a budget is a cult favorite
budgeting app for a reason
it works and i'm going to come back to
that cult favorite because oh my god
they really do have a cult following the
app and it's simple for rule method will
change the way you think about your
money and help you gain total control so
you can plan for the things you need and
get the things you want without guilt or
stress
to give you an idea on the cult favorite
side to date they know of at least seven
customers who have customized their
license plates to mark the occasion of
purchasing a new car in cash
and these fans do this by including ynab
you need a budget on their license place
so people love this app you need a
budget has helped millions of people
transform their finances save their
marriages and live life on their own
terms i even asked pete adney who's been
on the podcast best known as mr money
mustache super popular episode what he
thought and he's a big fan of the
founder and what they're doing so it was
check check check green light green
light green light across the board you
need a budget's simple four rule method
will actually teach you how to manage
your money you will learn a new way of
thinking new habits and new behaviors
that will help you get out of debt break
the paycheck to paycheck cycle and build
wealth faster the you need a budget team
is committed to your success they offer
free live classes every day of the week
video courses boot camps challenges and
active fan groups in every corner of the
internet there's something for everyone
if you want to learn they can teach you
that you need a budget team believes
that no one can tell you what your money
should do only you can decide what
matters most to you your budget is
simply a tool to help you stay focused
on your true priorities reach your goals
and live a life of your design on
average new budgeters save more than six
hundred dollars by month two and six
thousand dollars in their first year so
try the app free for 34 days no credit
card required at you need a budget dot
slash tim spelled as you would expect in
proper english try you need a budget
free for 34 days no credit card required
at you need a budget dot com slash tim
and just to explain 34 days that's
because most people reconcile at the end
of the month or 38 period so having a
couple of days of cushion helps folks
out so 34 days with no credit card
required at you need a budget dot com
slash time
this podcast episode is brought to you
by helix sleep
sleep is super important to me in the
last few years i've come to conclude it
is the end-all be-all that all good
things good mood good performance good
everything seem to stem from good sleep
so i've tried a lot to optimize and i've
tried pills and potions all sorts of
different mattresses you name it and for
the last few years i've been sleeping on
a helix midnight luxe mattress i also
have one in the guest bedroom and
feedback from friends has always been
fantastic it's something that they
comment on helix sleep has a quiz takes
about two minutes to complete that
matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you with helix there's a specific
mattress for each and every body that is
your body also your taste so let's say
you sleep on your side in like a super
soft bed no problem or if you're a back
sleeper who likes a mattress that's as
firm as a rock they've got a mattress
for you too helix was selected as the
number one best overall mattress pick of
2020 by gq magazine wired apartment
therapy and many others just go to
helixsleep.com
tim take their two-minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life they have a 10 year
warranty and you get to try it out for
100 nights risk-free they'll even pick
it up from you if you don't love it and
now my dear listeners helix is offering
up to hundred dollars off of all
mattress orders and two free pillows at
helixsleep.com
tim these are not cheap pillows either
so getting two for free is an upgraded
deal so that's up to 200 off and two
free pillows at helix sleep dot com
slash tim that's helix h-e-l-i-x
sleep.com
tim for up to 200 off so
check it out one more time helix
h-e-l-i-x sleep.com
tim
at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start to
shake can i ask you a personal question
now
[Music]
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissues
[Music]
boys and girls ladies and germs this is
tim ferriss and welcome to another
episode of the tim ferriss show my guest
today
is internet and technology entrepreneur
jimmy wales you can find him on twitter
at jimmy underscore wales he is founder
of the online non-profit encyclopedia
wikipedia and co-founder of the
privately owned wikia inc including its
entertainment media brand fandom powered
by wikia
wells serves on the board of trustees of
the wikimedia foundation the non-profit
charitable organization he established
to operate wikipedia in 2019 jimmy
launched wt social a news focused social
network in 2006 jimmy was named to time
magazine's list of the 100 most
influential people in the world for his
role in creating wikipedia jimmy welcome
to the show oh thanks for having me it's
good to be here
i've been looking forward to this it's
been many years before we hit record
seems like 100 years 99 of which you
mentioned are the last 12 months since
we last
saw each other
and
it's fun to reconnect and it also gave
me an excuse
to do what would seem very strange
with anyone i know on some level which
is putting together a dossier of
information like
some
some uh you know eastern
german intelligence officer in some type
of film but i learned a lot and i also
have a whole slew of questions
to ask and i thought we would begin
with
the beginning and
would love it if you could just take a
little bit of time to
describe
where you grew up and what your
family and education looked like in the
early days if you wouldn't mind starting
there i grew up i was born and grew up
in the deep south in alabama but i was
in huntsville alabama which is a little
bit different from what your typical
stereotype of alabama is in that after
world war ii they brought all the german
rocket scientists over put them in
huntsville to work on the space program
and they built the space program all of
the real science aspects of it were
built there in huntsville so it was it
was a high-tech town there was a point
in time i remember they used to brag
about locally when
huntsville had the highest
per capita number of phds in the country
so they brought all these amazing people
in to work on the space program and what
that meant for me as a kid growing up we
lived close enough to where they tested
the saturn v rockets that sometimes the
windows would rattle in the house
when they were testing the rockets so
that was kind of exciting and
it was a big deal and basically what it
meant was that the space program in
particular the scientists were like our
hometown sports team all the kids were
very much into it and so forth and
therefore
it made it natural for me to be into
computers and technology later on as
that anti-unfold what did your parents
spend their time doing if you could
paint a picture so my dad
was a grocery store manager for many
years managed the local grocery stores
and my mother was a school teacher and
in fact i
attended a school that my mother and my
grandmother set up which was a very
unusual
one-room school house so i grew up like
abraham lincoln there were four kids in
my class so therefore because it was so
small there were four kids in my class
but there were
four grades together at a time so we had
first through fourth grade and then
fifth through eighth grade
in two rooms
but what that meant was it was a very
flexible and unstructured kind of
education it wasn't everybody line up
and sit in rows in the same kind of way
i've compared it to montessori but it
was not technically speaking a
montessori school and that unfortunately
got reported wrong so on a lot of
montessori websites they list
me as one of the
graduates of montessori but that's not
technically true
what was cool about it is that we were
allowed to go ahead if we wanted to so
we would have our math workbooks
and then we would just if we just could
crash through our math workbook in the
first four months of school then we were
allowed to go and do other things with
our time and so i spent a lot of time
reading i spent a lot of time reading
encyclopedias because i really enjoyed
the encyclopedia and so it was a i think
a very conducive kind of education
to being an entrepreneur
slash it also probably ruined me from
having any kind of a normal job
because i'm used to sort of getting up
and saying oh what's interesting to do
today and i'll just do the interesting
thing that i can find to do
how is that informed
how you think about education for your
own kids
and how have you thought about that i
don't have kids but i expose them on the
cusp feeling the biological imperative
to
reason myself into having kids yeah
my oldest daughter kyra who's now in
college she's at university of miami she
was homeschooled her whole
sort of time growing up but that was
really quite particular to her it wasn't
really an ideological thing or you know
i never really in advance thought of
that but it just suited her i remember
we
took her to
tour a local school thinking about what
school she should go to
and then it's like she was getting ready
to go into kindergarten and i asked her
you know what did you think of that
school and she said oh that lady was
really funny she said they would teach
me how to read and she was on her third
harry potter book at the time so
we were like yeah and then
you know we went to another school a
year later and i said well what did you
think she said boring
so she didn't she didn't it didn't make
sense for her to go so later on she did
go to kind of a gifted program one day a
week and that sort of thing but it just
suited her she was better off just kind
of studying what she wanted to when she
wanted to and then my my two younger
kids here in london they have a much
more
straightforward you know they go to the
local school down the street where we
live in in london so it's much more of a
traditional normal education
how did you
and i think this will be of great
interest to
an incredible number of parents
particularly after
quarantine and covid how did you think
about or
decide on
how to approach homeschooling in terms
of teaching yourself vetting teachers
and so on
we went to
various homeschool
groups i mean it was kind of weird
actually because a lot of the
homeschooling community is extremely
religious which i am not and so
that whole world was a bit not to my
taste but there's a lot of great
resources out there but really i mean
the truth is her mother did it far more
than i did and that's just because of my
work causing me to travel and so on and
so forth i would say there was a
similarity to my childhood it was this
idea of like actually what really works
well if a kid is interested and
motivated
is just follow whatever you're
interested in i mean you know she got
interested in penguin she would read
five books about penguins and that was
that just incredibly powerful in terms
of mindset to just be free to pursue
whatever you're interested in i'm not
suggesting it's right for every family
uh right for every kid that's very much
a personal thing but
in general there's a lot of ways to
end up at 18
with a quality education and one of them
is to go through a traditional school
process
another one is to not go through a
traditional school process and and
pursue it in different ways
so you mentioned that you're not
particularly religious you also
mentioned that you've been incorrectly
cited as a graduate of montessori so i
want a fat check
something i've i've read i don't know if
you
self-describe as
a non-believer or atheist do you
self-describe that way or would you put
it differently you know i do
what is interesting is i at one point in
my wikipedia entry which i try not to
pay too much attention to because
i recommend that for everybody it can
drive you a bit crazy because it's your
uh i mean this really is a hilarious
sort of thing it's like more than
anything else it's your obituary but
it's written while you're alive
i mean there will be an obituary
published somewhere but it's not going
to be as important as your wikipedia
entry so that means that you can
probably pull heavily from your
wikipedia page you can you can feel
pretty strongly about it
but at one point in time they had put me
into a category of american atheists and
i said technically speaking that is true
but putting me into that category
is a very odd thing to do in the sense
that that is not what centrally defines
me
there are people like historically
madeline murray o'hare who was a massive
atheist activist and yes she's clearly
an american atheist like that that is
exactly a good description of who she
was but for me it's just like i don't
know it's a weird category to put me in
you know it's like putting me in a
category of
people who
eat ice cream you know it's like okay
yes that's true however i'm not really
sure that it's an encyclopedic fact so
it's not the defining characteristic
that you would
put on your business card if that if
that were still a thing
exactly did you come to
atheism of your own accord was that
something
absorbed through the household
how did you come to that point
my parents are
religious but not
i mean even though we're from the deep
south i wouldn't say they are
incredibly involved in it but they tick
the box and
we
went to a methodist church which is
quite mild church compared to some of
the very intense churches you can get in
the deep south
you know i mean i would say there were a
couple of
fun stories that are relevant here so
one fun story is when i was four
and i remember this very vividly so i
would have been born in august so it was
getting close to christmas so you know
four plus some and i
didn't you know the whole santa claus
thing was
i don't know i found that quite
perplexing and not not particularly
believable
and i came up with a very brilliant
experiment that ultimately had a deep
deep flaw in it but which was when i
went to the shopping mall with my
parents and i went and i sat on santa's
lap my mom was too far away to hear
everything
so santa asked me what i wanted for
christmas and i told him a bit of this
and that and then i mentioned in
particular i wanted a g.i joe
ranger van so this was actually a time
period i was born in 66 so at this time
period
i would say gi joe had become a little
bit less military and he was more of a
park ranger because everybody was not
that happy about the military due to
vietnam and all that
and i wanted this park ranger van gi joe
for my gi joe to play with
and i didn't tell mom
and dad i told them about a few other
things so christmas morning came and i
got everything i asked for that i told
my parents about but i did not get the
gi joe had
so this proved to me that this whole
santa thing was was a hoax but then i
realized literally on christmas morning
the flaw in my plan which was this was
the gift i wanted the most and i was
like why didn't i ask for something
stupid that i didn't even want to test
the theory so then i'm like oh great
i've ripped myself off i didn't get a
a gi joe van so there's that story which
was really i mean the relevance to your
question is just it was me having a
a doubting mind and a testing you know i
wanted to experiment i wanted to find
out the evidence for something
and then later on you know as as i grew
older i i really i came to a position
because there is a
a struggle with you know am i going to
go to hell the stories that people tell
kids about religion are quite terrifying
and i just finally thought you know what
if there is a good and kind and loving
god he wants me to be honest
and i can't honestly say i believe this
so if i go through my life and i don't
believe it and then i die i think god
will go you know what you came by it
honestly so come on in you know it's
fine i'm not asking for stupid blind
obedience because what meaning is there
to that so that kind of helped me get my
comfort with it and then later i studied
philosophy and
the various arguments for and against
and so on and so forth but i think for
me that emotional point where i could
say
okay look it's kind of the opposite of
pascal's wager if you're aware of that
it's kind of like i am yeah i'm gonna be
fine what did you think you were
possibly going to be or what did you
aspire to
do when you grew up when you were in say
high school
high school was when i actually i got
interested in
the stock market got interested in
finance
in a way kind of accidentally
and actually we could go back and look
at the timeline so if you go back in and
see
when did winnebago stock go from
three to 18 let's just say some kind of
numbers like that within a year's time
basically what happened was i had this
sort of moment of insight that
gas prices had been incredibly high
there was this whole inflationary crisis
and the recession and everything
and obviously winnebago sales were quite
down because who can afford to buy a big
thing to drive around in a recession and
then also gas prices were high
and then gas prices came tumbling down
and i said you know what i think
winnebago is going to have a great year
so i just started watching their stock
price and it went from three until 18
and i was like oh this is easy like
anybody can make that
so i have one good idea you know which
also reminds me people say if you could
go back and and tell yourself something
when you were 20 what would you say and
i would say buy apple stock
like literally
don't buy that car just buy apple stock
thank you later so i got interested in
finance in the markets and decided that
when i went to
college i would study finance so that's
kind of what i thought i would do
what appealed to you about finance and
markets you have this childhood of
following your interests whether that be
well in your daughter's case
hypothetically penguins or fill in the
blank what what was it that grabbed you
or compelled you about finance and
markets
well i mean i think in part it's just
this idea that it's a very intellectual
activity you know figuring out
the valuation of something i feel
i don't know excited by things that
demand of you
rationality really being objective like
if you
are trading or gambling
on the basis of some emotional feeling
with no facts behind it then on average
you're not going to do very well you
have to kind of be ruthless with
yourself of like am i investing in
tesla because i think elon musk is cool
or
am i actually overpaying for something
that's extraordinarily highly valued at
the moment and so i think that appealed
to me and then as i got further into it
just the mathematics of it i like math
and enjoy
thinking about things like arbitrage
where you buy and sell
something that's different but similar
you can actually figure out what the
relative valuation between the two
should be and it's the harder that is to
figure out then the more likely it's to
be mispriced
that's the sort of thing that i enjoyed
about it
were there or are there any
particular investors
who stood out or stand out to you
who capture your imagination perhaps
i would say
certainly
at this point in my life in particular i
would say
the long-term value investing type of
approach is something i see a lot of
wisdom in so warren buffett type of
investing
where you
definitely aren't trying to time the
market from day to day you aren't doing
the kind of arbitrage that brought me
into thinking about it and so forth it's
not about that it's about really
thinking about long-term trends and
patience and putting your money aside in
a way that i part of the reason i think
i have such abilities is something that
i never did
you know so i can joke about you know
buy apple stock when you're young but in
fact i've been an entrepreneur my whole
life so basically
i've never really built up a normal
retirement portfolio and things like
that i just put everything into the
projects i'm working on which is good
and bad but i mean i think that that
kind of idea of
and i think this is something that young
people have a hard time with
which is a weird kind of shame because
it's the time when it matters which is
compound interest really does matter if
you can earn x percent a year
it's kind of boring when you're young
but when you're old you look back and go
oh actually that's quite a pile of money
interesting
the value investing sort of buy and hold
as you mentioned the warren buffett you
get 10 hole punches for the rest of your
life how will you think about your
decisions
is also a fascinating thought exercise
even if you don't fully ascribe to it
because
there is a measure twice cut once
emphasis on
rational decision making and people
would argue well that's great and it
worked before 2014 really well before
fang and so on and so forth contributed
so much to the s p 500 or whatever it
might be is a counter argument but when
you read these annual letters of howard
marks or other
investors who
would often be put into that class they
talk quite a lot about cognitive
biases and different types of
malfunctions of reasoning that is
perhaps not emphasized at other places
when and how did
objectivism
enter
into the picture
so i like many people when i was i don't
know maybe 20 got
interested in i was interested in
philosophy and i was interested in
economics and got interested and very
excited by iron rand and
in particular the fountainhead being a
real mind-blowing eye-opening book for
me and so
really as i do tend to
pursue whatever interests me
i would say i go very very deep into
that whole world and i would say at a
point in time i would consider myself a
real expert in a lot of the real
details of that
body of thought and body of knowledge
and in many ways
still today has an impact on how i think
about things and what's problematic
about it is
that the general
understanding of her work that most
people have is so superficial it's a
cartoon caricature
of what her ideas actually were could
you describe for folks
for folks who have no familiarity
what is the caricature and then
sure yeah i think the thing she's most
known for is
her
advocacy of free market capitalism and
her advocacy of self-interest rational
self-interest and those are both true by
the way but they're also nuanced and
subtle and complicated in some really
interesting and different ways
and for me i think what i
would say impacted me more and you can
still see it in me today
is the idea that ideas matter
and that a really important and
incredibly valuable
thing to do in life as part of being a
successful flourishing human being
is to think and to chew on ideas
and so a lot of people have a very
knee-jerk approach to
what they think she was about
and even the knee-jerk approach is
something that i find irritating whether
you're for or against some of our ideas
it's really more like okay no let's
actually
slow down let's think about what we know
how do we know it how can we find out
what's true what does it mean to gather
evidence what does it mean to
reason based on evidence
uh and all of those things to me are
incredibly valuable i would almost say
in and of themselves but they're they're
not just in themselves they're towards
the end of being
a human being really and i suppose it's
one could also argue that even if
aspects of it and i'm just playing
devil's advocate here but if aspects of
it could be
rightly considered
cartoonish or exaggerated it doesn't
mean that there aren't
components that are incredibly still
incredibly practical and valuable
for sure and and you know it's like if
what you draw from her sort of sense of
life and philosophy and ideas is the
idea
i have a fundamental moral
responsibility to think really hard
about what's right and what's wrong
that's good you know like that's a
really good thing and if what you
conclude is yeah you know what she's
actually wrong about this aspect of
economics or she's actually wrong about
that aspect of interpersonal morality
that's okay because what you got from
that was that you're a thinking person
and for me i always say this and this is
really what i think is the best bits of
of wikipedia is
if i bump into someone and we disagree
about some ideas
and
i find myself having to grapple with and
think through their perspective and
understand it whether i come out of the
other end agreeing with them or not
that's an incredibly valuable thing and
i i will love that person who has sort
of grappled with me in an equal kind of
intellectual way
that's hugely fascinating and for me
this is one of the the sad things about
twitter for example
is that there's just the design of the
space is so bad for that the design of
the space is really all about
the one-line quip that destroys someone
with a humor whether or not you even
bothered engaging with what they had to
say
for me it's just so much more valuable
to
to really kind of understand someone
even if i end up disagreeing with them
you mentioned design of the space with
reference to twitter
when were you first exposed to
design of any space
online
in a meaningful way well i mean in a
sense obviously the minute everyone gets
on online in in whatever space you're in
you're subjected to the design elements
of that space even though you may not
have thought through it but i mean i
remember getting on
very early on to usenet groups
so for those who aren't ancient like me
and may not remember or know about
usenet usenet was an enormous sprawling
kind of message board system but unlike
say reddit which is probably the in some
ways the successor
it was not only
kind of uncensored it was also
uncensorable because it was a
peer-to-peer system shared across many
many networks it was basically a
protocol for exchanging data where this
sprang up
and the cabal that was loosely in charge
of it did begin to build ways of
canceling posts
by sending commands to cancel things
that the other servers could or could
respect or not respect and so on and so
forth to try and bring it under control
because what happened in that design was
a lot of really really really bad
behavior
a lot of abuse a lot of flame wars so
people started creating moderated groups
which
had a lot of problems so i i was very
interested in that space and as i was
using usenet
as a reader you know just like anybody
would use reddit or something today
i got very interested in
because i was studying economics and
game theory i'm very interested in
thinking through
okay what are the incentive structures
so everyone who's participating here
they're facing because of the design of
the software because the social design
of the space they face various
incentives and the incentives you know
might be there was of course spammers so
people would just come and just spam
news group with useless advertising and
things like that so okay that's that's
one incentive structure people have
and you know like one of the things and
this is something i would say today is
true
of twitter which is
because of the way twitter works
let's say you see somebody doing
something terrible on twitter so abusing
another person abusing you whatever it
might be
spamming well what are your choices what
are the three things you can do and they
are this that you could block that other
person which helps you but doesn't help
anybody else you can report it but
because their their reporting on abuse
system doesn't scale very well because
it's very just top down and there's
a very sad job involved that people have
to look at the worst things in humanity
and make judgment calls at very low cost
so therefore they're overworked
underpaid and they're doing
a great service at great personal
expense i believe
or you can yell at them
that's your third choice is to yell at
the person which if you've ever been on
twitter is very popular you know it's
like just yell yell at them they're
yelling at you you just yell back and
there you go and so to some extent
usenet was like that you would go into a
little friendly little unmoderated news
group on some subject you're interested
in and it could go very well for a
little while and then as it got bigger
and bigger eventually
you would see oh this is now dominated
by
the most annoying person here and the
second most annoying person here and all
they're doing is yelling at each other
you know and it's kind of like good
people are like yeah you know what i'm
out of here like this isn't the
interesting place to chew on ideas this
is just people screaming at each other
and so that kind of thing made me start
to think a lot about okay what are the
principles of designing
software but also designing social rules
and norms
that can help contribute to
building something that's healthy that's
meaningful to people as opposed to just
creating yet another sort of cesspit on
the internet
creating another neighborhood that
features people throwing potted plants
at your head as you walk down the slide
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by
athletic greens i get asked all the time
what i would take if i could only take
one supplement the answer is invariably
athletic greens i view it as all-in-one
nutritional insurance i recommended it
in fact in the 4-hour body this is more
than 10 years ago and i did not get paid
to do so with approximately 75 vitamins
minerals and whole-food-sourced
ingredients you'd be very hard-pressed
to find a more nutrient-dense and
comprehensive formula on the market it
has multi vitamins multi-mineral greens
complex probiotics and prebiotics for
gut health and immunity formula
digestive enzymes adaptogens and much
more i usually take it once or twice a
day just to make sure i've covered my
bases if i miss anything i'm not aware
of of course i focus on nutrient-dense
meals to begin with that's the basis but
athletic greens makes it easy to get a
lot of nutrition when whole foods aren't
readily available from travel packets i
always have them in my bag when i'm
zipping around right now athletic greens
is giving my audience a special offer on
top of their all-in-one formula which is
a free vitamin d supplement and five
free travel packs with your first
subscription purchase many of us are
deficient in vitamin d i've found that
true for myself which is usually
produced in our bodies from sun exposure
so adding a vitamin d supplement to your
daily routine is a great option for
additional immune support support your
immunity gut health and energy by
visiting athleticgreens.com
tim you'll receive up to a year's supply
of vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your subscription again that's
athleticgreens.com
so we're going to segue to
the onset of
entrepreneurship
so to speak before we get there because
you mentioned the fountainhead
and i may lose track of this question i
want to ask are there any
books in particular that you have gifted
often or more often than others to other
people is there a short list of any type
or any that come to mind
not really gifted but but in the sense
of gifted or recommended let's just say
recommended i would say
there are two they're both quite simple
in a way as recommendations and quite
common but one one would be
seven habits of effective people
which is a classic stephen covey kind of
motivation self-help kind of thing i
wouldn't say that i have applied all of
it or buy into all of it but i did find
at a certain point in my life being a
person who's
prone to
following whatever interests me at the
moment it's like okay pull myself
together and here's a system for like
getting things done
i tried looking into getting things done
which is a more contemporary kind of
popular thing and thought it was quite
interesting and good but i didn't buy
into it and i felt like you needed to
really buy into it to make that work so
seven habits and then the other one is a
book called
your money or your life which
is basically sets force the argument
that
you don't need as much money as you
think to live and in fact a lot of how
we live which is very expensive
traps us into things that we would
rather not be trapped into so you know
you've got to commute you've got to wear
certain clothes you've got gotta do this
that and the other certainly
something that i feel like you would
also
resonate with with four hour work week
which by the way also had a huge impact
on me my favorite story about that is
i read four hour work week and then i
not that long after that i was like okay
[ __ ] this i'm moving to argentina for a
month and i did
and i got a
a vantage phone with a number that rang
as if i were in new york so i got into
my apartment in buenos aires and nobody
knew i was there they all thought i was
in new york
because i was working remote anyway
i realized the flaw in my plan because
that month when i was supposed to be
there
i needed to do a speech to be fair on me
these speeches came up after i had
already booked the apartment and had
plans to go i had to go and give a
speech in korea and a speech in milan
i got to tell you to get from buenos
aires to seoul south korea that's just
there's no way like it's there's no path
to get there
it's like you've got to fly around the
world twice to get to that place so it
was a hopeless
month i'm like okay well i still love
the idea but anyway i don't want to
embarrass you by recommending your book
on your show but i assume everybody
who's listening will have read that but
you know it's like really interesting
because what i like about your money or
your life and what i liked about your
book
is kind of that like okay hold on you're
doing this whole thing you've got this
whole rat race thing going on you're
following all the normal things why
don't you just step back and go hey is
there a radical different way of looking
at this
to say is there a way i can make my life
like super much better and still kind of
do the things that i want to do
but without all the things that are
blocking me from doing it because i have
to make the money to make the money to
do things you know it's kind of that
cycle you can get into well thank you
for thank you for sharing and thank you
for the kind words i love the argentina
story there's always there's almost
always a wrinkle in the master plan
i'm in chiang mai but uh oh i forgot
i could not have foreseen
the amazing ping pong like travel plan
that i will now have ahead of me
how did you go from or maybe this was
the intention all along i don't know but
how did you go from finance and markets
to
founding
companies
exactly i was working as a futures and
options trader in chicago
worked for a small firm of local traders
so local traders are traders who were
you know on the floor i wasn't working
at a big bank where we owned our seats
on the floor and and we traded
with the firm's money and
i was doing arbitrage between
the chicago mercantile exchange and the
chicago board of trade for headphones
and libor if anybody's really want to
geek out on what all that is
and as a result i actually had
the markets open quite early there 7 20
and finish it two i could be out of the
office by three
and i was just super interested in
technology super interested in the
internet i had been using the internet
when i was in grad school quite a lot
and i could see this thing brewing that
was really something very interesting
and i
was interested so i one of the things i
was doing because i was geek also i just
moved chicago didn't know anybody didn't
really have a life so i would get off
work and i would go home and i would do
programming
and i was writing a web browser so just
from scratch or using various components
i could find online open source stuff
writing my own web browser and when i
was in the middle of doing that and it
was you know barely functional to be
fair that was when netscape went public
and netscape on the first day of trading
was worth something like 4.3 billion
dollars and i saw that number 4.3
billion and i was like you know what
netscape 1.0 is better than my web
browser that i'm writing at home but
it's not 4.3 billion dollars better
like
it's kind of not that brilliant a piece
of software and it wasn't you know it
was like really early days and so i was
like this is really interesting and i've
been excited about the internet for a
few years but this is for the first time
the market validating this is going to
be a big thing this is quite interesting
i had a friend tam shell and he and i
started tinkering around on the internet
and we we did a bunch of different stuff
we
started a little web directory search
engine called bomus which was basically
about
building web directories so you could go
in and well web rings we called it so
you could go in and create a list of
websites on any topic and just link them
all together to each other so that other
people could come and
what was interesting about that is we
and and the the foreshadowing bit for
the future is
we decided that we would just let people
come in and build these web rings so you
could sign up for an account and create
a list of anything you wanted and the
idea was really an early you know it was
like yahoo links you know so yahoo used
to have i mean maybe they still have i
don't know but they had a web directory
rather than a right google style search
engine and they would categorize things
and they hired staff to do it and so
there was a big giant list of links with
categories and subcategories and we're
like oh maybe anybody could help us
build that why would you need to hire
staff to do that so that's kind of the
early
user generated content concept
and then we tried a lot of different
things over a few years time we had i
would say early blogging slashdot was a
big tech
news site that was massively popular at
the time and they open sourced their
code slash code they called it so we
grabbed that and started opening a bunch
of different blogs trying to
leverage the traffic we had built
and you know it went well for a while so
so it was growing and it was doing well
and
it was the dot-com boom and then we got
approached by
this is actually really funny and a
great story we got approached by
nbc
tv network you know nbc nbci with nbc
interactive because at that time i mean
it sounds like a joke today it sounded
kind of like a joke back then but they
were very dead serious
they thought okay the big tv network
should move into like why should these
upstarts like yahoo and google
we're going to create a web portal and a
search engine
and we're going to have all these
different web properties it's going to
be just like a tv network
so they started building things and so
they paid us
a lot of money they bought out our full
inventory for far more than we've been
able to sell it forever
and in exchange we moved the whole site
to
bomas.nbci.com so we became a sub domain
of theirs so that they could count our
traffic
for their
media metrics numbers
and
we were about 10 of their traffic which
was kind of interesting because they
didn't pay us nearly 10 of what they
were blowing on everything
[Laughter]
and so there for a short period of time
that was like really our dot-com boom
era like it was amazing we were making
good money and then
lo and behold
they realized somebody higher up
realized they were spending about a
hundred million a quarter
losing 100 million a quarter
and they were like you know what we
better stop doing this like this is
definitely not working this is a really
bad idea so then we had a bit of a
contract dispute at the end because they
were just like okay [ __ ] you we're not
paying you anymore and i was like [ __ ]
you got a contract and you know whatever
a tiny company versus a giant company
yeah you just take what they give you
because there's no way of fighting it
really so
so then we went back so then we were
sort of off of there and then
that was actually a really complicated
time and i can't tell you whether i
would have to really go back and study
was that before or after the founding of
newpedia which was the first
encyclopedia project it was probably
around the same time because i think
that that wealth made us feel like hey
we can launch some new things let's take
this money that's coming in and let's
see what else we can create
and
that was when we started thinking about
the encyclopedia project i would say
a couple of questions related to the
stories you just shared
that the first is
at what point did you leave your
finance job ah yeah what experiments
were with the safety net of this
background of employment and when did
you make the jump
out
so my
my boss as i say it was a small firm we
had i think there were probably 20 staff
total and my boss was a trader himself
and he
sort of knew that i was going home at
night working his stuff on the weekend
and that tim and i were sort of thinking
about website ideas i mean really
actually i kind of glossed over we had a
couple of
i would say brilliant ideas that we
we weren't able to pull off so one was
autotrader.com so basically i was like
people could post ads for the cars they
want to sell and
get in touch and and so we went to car
dealers they weren't interested so
i had this idea for ordering food online
which of course now is a huge business
and
at the time again restaurant owners
looked at me like i was from mars when i
would go in and go i want to put your
restaurant online and they're like
we've got a fax machine we don't know
what you're talking about
but we were doing this and that and then
the the web ring concept started to take
off and we could show like you know
traffic is increasing increasing and
michael was a trader uh my boss and had
seen sort of the markets go wild and i
was like hey you know i think i can
build something here
and he became an angel investor he
invested
some money not a huge amount but enough
that
i was able to
kind of carry on paying myself a little
bit of a salary and and tim a salary and
we hired a couple more programmers and
so on also moved to san diego because i
was fed up with the chicago weather we
started that way and in terms of that
feeling of that moment when do you jump
ship it felt okay because it was quite
clear
that michael and i got along well he
liked my work as a trader he thought
this sounded cool and interesting too
i did feel like okay if this whole thing
doesn't work i can just go back to
chicago and start trading again like it
wasn't it didn't feel like
cutting ship and i'm never going to get
to come back to my old career which not
everybody has that you know there are
certain careers
some of the worst are
places that i consider to be virtually
like cults when people join them but
like the big consulting and accounting
firms where they've got a really rigid
kind of up or out culture
where if you think you're about to make
partner in two years time which is a fat
salary it'd be kind of crazy to quit
even though you you're unhappy because
you know you might get fired anyway or
you might make partners so you know it's
like a weird sick kind of life i wasn't
in that kind of situation it was like a
very entrepreneurial company i was
working for so therefore it felt like
okay look this is a side thing i want to
do it to him it was just like another
trade it's like okay we put some money
on this and see how it works out just
like you know it's like here jimmy used
some money to trade with let's see how
it works out
right and if it doesn't work out there
are
other options there are follow-up
opportunities yeah and i talk about this
none of this was in silicon valley but
i talk about this particularly in places
you know i travel all over the world
what i used to this year just in my
attic but
i think one of the great things about
silicon valley is precisely this concept
which people get in a very deep way
which is if you try a startup
and it doesn't work out
that's not the end of your career you're
not forever a failure at all then you
get a job at google and if you're
interviewing for jobs in silicon valley
having been at a startup that didn't
work out isn't a black mark in fact it
can be quite interesting if people can
look at and go that's interesting you
were working on
food delivery two years before it came a
big thing that's actually not a good
example because that's been a big thing
for a long time now but you know it's
like oh wow that's interesting because
you were too early or you missed it
because of this than the other but
actually that was a great idea
and your talent is so great not not a
problem and i think in a lot of
societies around the world i mean i have
talked to
japanese entrepreneurs korean
entrepreneurs and they really struggle
with this
that this idea that
if i go and work at a startup and it
fails
my whole career is doomed like i've
missed the boat i should have gone to
work for a big company and i think
that's unfortunate because it fails to
generate the culture that can generate
innovation
it highlights a number of things for me
as we're talking and rather as i'm
listening
number one the cultural consequences
both
internationally but even domestically
are different depending on
location the financial consequences and
the optionality that you have or don't
have are also
affected by
your choices in this case of say
employment right what type of
game are you signing up for
what are the incentives like your boss
viewed it as another trade he's like
sure i'll stake this guy it's like
you're at a blackjack table and you have
possibly a system for beating the odds
like yeah right yeah let's let let's try
it i have to make sure that he has
enough money that he can
survive like a short string of bad luck
but let's see what happens
versus as you put it maybe in you know
big five accounting firm or somewhere
else where it's it's up or out and the
game is kind of zero-sum and then you
have to completely switch lanes and
i want to come back to
actually one
question that if i don't ask is going to
bother me how did the
television network find
the web ring was it
dominant enough that it was on
everyone's radar or was there something
else that that happened because that
seemed to provide the fuel
for
some of what happened later how did that
actually come together
i would say no we weren't we were by no
means dominant we only ever had a little
bit of press coverage it wasn't it
wasn't like a famous thing
we were on certain lists so back then
there were a few
sort of like today you could look on
alexa and get the alexa ranking of
something and it isn't very accurate
necessarily but it's it's the thing
that's out there and so i think you
could look us up and see oh this has a
lot of traffic or a fair amount of
traffic but i actually think
i literally have no idea i mean i got a
call out of the blue and they're like
well we don't want to buy you but we'd
be interested in this type of
partnership i think they did that type
of deal with a lot of different sites i
think they were just looking to build
out and in a way if you think about
a tv network that's kind of their
mindset this is like paying for
a production company to create a show so
we're going to go out and we're going to
find a production company and a writer
and we're going to back them to build
this thing and they're not necessarily
actually making the tv shows they're
working with other companies to do it i
think that was kind of their view it's
like let's put some money in and let's
sponsor and let's let's bring onto our
network 50 of these things to generate a
bigger property but i i literally have
no idea how they found me that's a good
question and i would imagine there's
some behind the scenes although
predictable conversation on their part
which is
some type of arbitrage right they're
saying hey look we can pay these guys x
and then we can charge 2x for the cpm of
the advertising even though they ended
up losing 100 million per quarter which
isn't ideal but it makes sense they
would just try to roll up a bunch of
this traffic and then sell it for a
multiple of some type yeah no i i think
it was slightly different from that
because that is a perfectly valid
strategy today it's not uncommon that a
successful smaller website gets bought
by a bigger company for the simple
reason that the bigger company has
traction in the ad sales market and can
get more so it's a win-win you know like
they can pay you more for your small
website than you would make on your own
and and they can arbitrage and make
money on it that's great
but in this case i i believe because it
was the dot-com frenzy i think it was
really more if we can get big enough
that we can go to the market and say
we're as big as google and that's worth
this mile of billions we can spin it out
for those billions that's kind of
amazing
whether they could actually make money
or not as a real business because this
was in the dot com mania which by the
way is
mostly leftist but i i would say there's
a lot of this stuff going on now
where
people are more interested in can we
blow up big enough
to sell to the market before it kind of
becomes obvious that this isn't actually
a great business
the new new economy as it was back yeah
exactly
now you mentioned a few different
kind of shots that you took you
mentioned food you mentioned this
autotrader like
concept
you were
trying
different things
presumably to see what would stick what
might gain some traction but you don't
have
infinite time right you have this finite
resource of time
so you can't try everything how did you
choose these particular
shots
so really
seat of the pants gut you know i i would
say
certainly not through
a
long
process like you might engage in if you
were
a big five accounting firm or a
consulting firm coming in to advise
where you would create
lists of 25 opportunities and then tick
through the pros and cons of each one
you didn't write a 100 page white paper
for yourself before exactly and in fact
later on when when i was
realized that it would be a good time to
start thinking about raising venture
capital like one of the things that was
really impossible for me is
to sort of write a business plan in the
traditional sort of mba school kind of
way because i'm like i just
most of the numbers you're going to
write down are complete fiction because
you know it's like yeah write a
three-year you know revenue estimate i'm
like oh wow
i don't know what it like
the numbers you pick the numbers i don't
really that's kind of not possible and
so it was actually good good vcs know
that and don't waste your time with a
lot of nonsense so that's kind of how
that worked i would say it would have to
do with did i find it personally
interesting did i think we could
leverage where we were to get somewhere
so just as one example
we knew because of the web rings
people were coming in and building
things and we knew what was most popular
on our site which was basically female
actresses and porn stars that was
massively popular in our search there
was so much of our traffic and so we're
like okay
that's weird what are people who are
into
pamela anderson who was huge like she
was our number one thing for a long time
what are people who are into pamela
anderson also into and we're like well
they're into tv they're into sports
they're basically men
so let's figure out that so we started a
baseball blog and
just stuff like that didn't really work
but that was kind of the thinking on
some of the projects is to go like we've
got this big audience what else could we
do with them and what might be a good
thing to do other ones like the food one
and the used car when those were all
before any success so those are just
like random ideas of let's build a
website what could it be
and then you've started looking at these
adjacent opportunities once you had
identified the type of people who are
providing traction yeah exactly although
to be clear though
the newpedia project was not something i
thought there was adjacent traffic to it
was kind of like
actually
this idea of a free encyclopedia for
everyone that's just
awesome meaningful
so that was really much more
there was no clear business idea no
business plan no nothing it was just i
think i know how to build this i'm just
going to build it and we'll figure the
rest out later which is also kind of a
dot-com era thing don't really know a
business model but i just know this
sounds like a cool thing and if if it's
a cool thing we'll find a way to fund it
eventually the field of dreams approach
yeah uh they build it and they will come
yeah and in this case just so i
understand the transition so you have
this web ring you partner with this
network you
begin to
amass enough capital that you have fuel
for whatever purpose you may decide
and then this deal falls through big
company you know huge company versus
small company contract dispute forget
about it right just bloodletting
exercise
did you have to make the decision to
abandon the audience and what you had
built to then jump to new pedia with no
real plan for
business or revenue or was it an easier
decision than i'm making it out to be it
was i mean i would say the immediate
thing that happened and a great lesson
for entrepreneurs
immediately after we lost the big sweet
deal
we basically started looking for another
deal looking for partners and we
basically carried on and over the course
of a year we we basically spent all the
money that we had made during the term
of the deal
and what i should have done
is recognize that we were in a dot-com
crash long before i could admit it to
myself and that there was going to be no
more sweetheart deal like that like that
that was just ridiculous and they were
overpaying and we weren't going to find
any way of making that much money
and i could have
cut the staff sooner what we did though
we were i think i would say we were
about 18 to 20 people when the deal blew
up
obviously we didn't hire anybody and
then people move on in any kind of
company so you know a couple people left
for their own reasons somebody moved
away and so on and we didn't replace
them so we were slowly starting to cut
expenses but being young and feeling
responsible for people who work for me
and all that i found it very hard to
just like lay people off that's just not
my
strong point of being like
kind of brutal with people and stuff and
they're doing good work we're gonna find
a way we just have to find a revenue
stream and so on
and then a black friday came
when
it was just like yeah this is it like i
can't carry on like this we're literally
not going to make payroll
for another month if we don't
dramatically cut and so we did we went
down from i think on that day
we went from 16 people to four
that was a pretty
brutal time
but 16 people down to four
it was okay because we could pay
ourselves that actually matched our
revenue to our expenses
and so
as a part of all that it was possible to
carry on and to sort of carry on at a
lesser level
and in fact we did then i moved from
california to florida because it was
cheaper we looked at saving money every
way we could we didn't have an office we
started all working remote because why
waste money on office if you're barely
paying your own salaries
and it was around that time that
wikipedia then had been started and
basically just started to boom it was
just growing and growing we were having
fun working on it and we're like wow
this is now
bigger than anything we ever made before
and that's kind of cool and exciting but
again it was it was not a moment of
we have to give up this one thing
and take this huge step
to do this other thing it was more like
okay this thing
we don't see any way to make a lot of
money out of it it's not really working
although it's popular it's not really
the right thing this other thing which
is our side project is actually doing
well so let's actually go that way for a
while and see how that goes meanwhile
the other thing just kind of sat there
making money not a huge amount of course
but it's like this is enough to pay
ourselves to work on this other thing
i certainly want to dive into
new pedia and then
what evolved from there but before i do
i have to ask since you mentioned you
know i should have
cut head count earlier to stem the
bleeding
when i begin to fantasize about that
what if
there's part of me that thinks wow
sometimes you need life to save you from
what you want because if you had
potentially done that
triage
yeah who knows maybe you'd still be
working at that company for all we know
for sure i mean one of the so as we get
from newpedia into wikipedia really
one of the things so i always say
wikipedia is a child of the dot-com
crash really now it was started before
the crash you know it was kind of going
but what i mean by that is
when wikipedia really started to grow
there was no possibility of getting any
investment money there was no
possibility of raising money to do it it
wasn't big enough that if we put ads on
it it wouldn't have made a material
difference it wasn't going to change
everything to be able to put a few ads
on and get a couple grand a month or
whatever it might have been
and what that meant was
interestingly okay imagine you start a
community website let's call it youtube
and it starts to grow and boom and
you're really excited and you see some
problems on the site and you think okay
what are we going to do about these
problems and what do you think first is
okay let's hire moderators like let's
hire people to do content moderation and
behavior moderation
and
had we had funding to do it we might
have evolved into the same type of model
that we see
at
twitter
youtube facebook like everywhere
basically which is the users use the
site and the moderation other than just
person-to-person blocking is really done
in a very opaque way by the company
itself and the difference with wikipedia
what makes it so fundamentally different
from everything else on the internet is
because i had zero money to hire
moderators we were actually forced to
invent ways to deal with things in the
community so we started to think about
okay what would it mean to have
moderators like admins
from the community volunteer admins so
it's like okay well there needs to be
checks and balances so they're elected
by the community they've got certain
rules they can lose their adminship if
they do the wrong things and then you
can go on wikipedia and there's to this
day there's hundreds and hundreds of
pages of discussions and debates about
all of these kinds of things but the key
is it's all in the hands of that
community and we had to devise things
like the arbitration committee which is
like the highest supreme court and
there's a million little things in
wikipedia
whereas
if we had had money probably we wouldn't
have done it that way probably would
have never occurred to me to do it that
way it was really necessity is the
mother of invention kind of thing i
remember reading a quote which i'm
absolutely going to butcher but it was
from jack ma the founder or perhaps
co-founder of alibaba
and it was along the lines of when we
started we had
several huge advantages we had no money
no plan and no experience
and
it's just incredible what you see and i
look back also at my own investing
career if i want to dignify it with such
a term and
almost all of the best investments were
in the
what was described at the time as dot
com depression in 2008 early 2009 after
the subprime mortgage crisis because i
think in part there's a survivorship
bias of course i mean you have kind of
the diehards who remain
but there was incredible resourcefulness
by necessity throughout that entire
period
and i don't want to skip over newpedia
because there are reasons i suspect why
people know
widely of wikipedia not so much newpedia
so what
didn't work
at newpedia and when did you know this
is really not going to work
so newpedia was the same vision free
encyclopedia freely licensed but i
didn't know anything about
building communities really i didn't
know anything about wiki software which
was
around at the time but i didn't know
about it really and
it had a seven stage review process to
get anything published so the idea was
which seemed correct given what we knew
at the time was actually incorrect
although it does foreshadow something
that
if you're going to be an encyclopedia
written by volunteers on the internet
then people are going to make fun of you
unless you're more academic than a
traditional encyclopedia you've got to
be really really super serious otherwise
it sounds ridiculous
and so that actually was
plausible and correct and so on and so
forth but what it meant was we built a
system that was not any fun it was very
intimidating
and you know to answer your question of
when did i know
well
basically we were i don't know maybe a
year in
and a point came when i was frustrated
because i'm like it's really slow
progress nothing's getting through the
system we've hardly published anything
what is wrong why can't we produce
content and i thought well i'm going to
just write an article myself
and i decided to write about robert
merton who won the nobel prize in
economics for his work in option pricing
theory when i was in grad school i had
published a paper on option pricing
theory and i'd worked in the markets in
chicago so i knew that area quite well
and i thought i'll just write a short
biography of merton i'd read all of his
academic papers and work through the
math of all of his work and you know
and so i sat down to write and i had a
massive immediate writer's block because
i knew they were going to take my
biography and they were going to send it
to the most prestigious finance
professors they could find to critique
and review it
and it was like no fun like that's scary
and i was like i'm gonna write this
thing and i'm gonna get it back it's
gonna be full of how stupid i am because
i haven't been in academia for four
years i left that world
and i realized then i'm like this is
never going to work this isn't fun this
is too hard and so that was when we
effectively
pivoted to
a wiki model where it's just like okay
here's a blank screen type some stuff
and let's start writing an encyclopedia
and in fact the reason it was called
wikipedia rather than just pivoting new
pd is that we thought
that our very very serious new pedia
community would be radically against
this that they would be very academic
and like that's crazy you can't do it
that way so we're like okay let's just
try it as a side project
and it took off it took off very very
quickly i mean we got more work done in
two weeks than we had in two years
nearly two years and that was very
exciting and actually just that one
little side note that's really
interesting when we were pursuing the
new pedia model
one of the earliest pieces that we
published to great fanfare with our
small community we're like great it's
past the seventh stage
and here it is
and it took a couple of days only before
somebody emailed and said um this is
actually plagiarized here's where it
came from
and we're like oh really and we looked
into it like oh so the whole academic
review process with professors looking
at everything didn't catch the
plagiarism nearly as fast as showing it
to 200 people and then just like
googling and checking it and so that was
like a really interesting insight to go
actually open peer review sort of the
open review much like open source
software
is actually quite powerful and may
actually catch things that a small group
review even of experts
won't catch and so that was quite
informative really i'd love to ask you
how you came across
wiki
software and in the course of doing
homework for this conversation i came
across and again i
can't believe everything you read but a
description of how tim berners-lee who i
believe is not too far from you across
the pond uh who's best known as the
inventor of the world wide web was
distraught when mosaic came out because
it was effectively read-only we were
talking about netscape earlier and and
he really wanted people to be able to
modify web pages i'm
very liberally paraphrasing my
interpretation there but
then this this software
provides that capability how are you
or your team exposed to that
the first i was exposed to it so jeremy
rosenfeld was one of my
employees he worked for me and
did a bit of this in that writing he
came to me and showed me a wiki it was
just before christmas and
said hey you know i've heard you talking
about how we have to make it simpler for
people to participate have you seen wiki
and i'm like no what's wiki and he
showed it to me and then not long after
i sort of posted on ward cunningham
who's the inventor of the wiki concept
basically wiki just means a website
anyone can edit
and i asked what do you think about
using a wiki to make an encyclopedia and
he responded quite famously something
like
yeah you could use wiki from writing
encyclopedia but it would still be a
wiki which was quite funny
so then my daughter was born the one who
was later homeschooled and she was very
very sick when she was born and it was
quite an emotional traumatic time
just like wow and it's kind of one of
those real
throughout the conversation i told you
no that wasn't really like a break point
moment and there was no moment of just
leaping and you know it was all
transitional from one to the next but
that was like a huge moment
so when she got home from the hospital i
was just like you know what life's too
short we've been thinking about trying
this wiki thing we're just going to go
for it i'm just going to install this
wiki software so i downloaded a an open
source wiki package that was very very
basic
set up it typed hello world and we were
off to the races
that was really that moment when
it was like okay let's
let's just make this happen i'm looking
at a
paragraph
from an esquire article esquire uk and
i'm just going to read
two sentences one or two sentences here
wikipedia is a universe unto itself it's
ambition unequaled and it's scale
unprecedented it's 300 that number i'm
sure has changed over time staff and
contractors are fond of a single phrase
quote thank god our little enterprise
works in practice because it could never
work in theory end quote
and
often to this day
i'm
continually
amazed that wikipedia works and you know
the article continues in theory
wikipedia should be a disaster etc etc
what were some of the decisions because
of course wikipedia has evolved over
time and a lot has been learned and
added to the ecosystem over time but
what were some of the
early decisions that ended up in your
mind being deciding factors for that
sort of minimally viable product that
that made it catch right in those first
few months
just to be clear and you the way you
said it is correct
sometimes that quote is attributed to me
i've never said that
not even sure i agree with that i think
it works in theory it works in practice
because it works in theory but that's
that's all complicated
so i i would say
key decisions that made a huge huge
difference that were really kind of open
questions in the early days
where things like
neutrality so the idea of
there was a proposal early on that maybe
instead of having one entry about
let's say
abortion a controversial topic seven one
entry about abortion why don't we just
have competing entries so different
people can write whatever they want and
and then you know they can vote on them
or just a competing interest and i was
like you know what i no i actually i
want there to be a neutral entry which
kind of tries to take into account all
points of view describes them fairly
doesn't take sides but just explains the
ideas
and i think that was hugely important
because the thing about
neutrality is
that all kinds of diverse people as long
as they're thoughtful and kind can get
behind that they can go okay yeah like i
i get that that's okay and you wouldn't
know it from
watching tv debates or going on twitter
but most people are pretty reasonable
and will say like i disagree with this
but it should be presented in a fair way
that the
defenders of it would identify so
that was a key one i think another one
was the idea i mean this is weird now to
think this was a big decision but it
really was at the time so somebody
started to
upload into wikipedia
the full text of hamlet for example
and that was like okay what do we what
do we think about that and i was like
you know what
hamlet should be available for free
online in a well-supported way
but it's not an encyclopedia article and
so it doesn't belong in wikipedia so we
created a separate project called
wikisource where people put all kinds of
source texts you know things like that
so it was a lot of those kinds of things
i mean tim shell who was my business
partner from the earliest days
when we first started there was no such
thing as a separate talk page
and he said if this is ever really going
to be an encyclopedia we need to
separate the discussions about the
articles from the articles themselves so
in a separate page and he proposed using
slash talk would create a subpage
well that was genius right nobody knew
it at the time and now it seems so
obvious you're like yeah so what but
actually it made a huge difference
because it meant that you could say
look whatever discussions and debates
you have put them over there
talk about how to improve the article
but the article itself you should always
try to keep it in a readable format as
an encyclopedia article whereas before
that what we would do is if you objected
to something in the middle of an entry
you would just go in and put in a
parenthetical remark or you would indent
a paragraph and comment on what was just
written which made it very hard to read
other than just as a interesting tool
for a weird wiki type of conversation
listening to you
list off these different decisions and
maybe this is being really dramatic but
it seems like any one of those taken in
a different direction could have
mortally wounded the entire enterprise i
don't know maybe that's
overstated but i mean that seems to be a
set of very critical decisions
were there any
significant mistakes
made in the early days that
either ended up needing to be fixed or
that
have just as kind of like a vestigial
tale have have remained
in the system were there any mistakes
that particularly come to mind as
memorable in the beginning days which
could be the first few months first few
years whatever time frame i always have
a hard time with this type of question
and i i always explain what i mean by
saying i'm a pathological optimist
so i always think everything's gonna be
great that's not correct by the way
everything is not always gonna be great
but that's the way i feel and approach
things so when i look back at the past
what i know is
we did the best given our knowledge of
the time so even let's say the first
attempt with newpedia clearly didn't
work
and so you can imagine in a fantasy kind
of way oh we could have just started
wikipedia two years earlier instead of
doing this whole new pedia detour which
didn't work but then again i'm like you
know what we learned a lot that detour
was kind of a necessary part of the
growth of
people in the community of myself
that i don't know how we could have
skipped that step and so it's kind of
like saying
yes i could be the greatest player in
the nba other than the fact that i'm
five foot seven
and not athletic at all but had i been
you know it would have been completely
different yeah but i'm not and i never
was so you know had i been genius enough
to figure out that the newpedia project
wasn't going to work two years earlier
then great but how can i regret that
like i wasn't that genius and i can't
play basketball so you know it's kind of
like
that so
for me i think this is when i'm talking
to people who are interested in being
entrepreneurs or thinking about their
career
things like that is to say look you have
to sort of get your mind to a point
where you
really
do believe because it's true
that
doing this thing
that even if it doesn't work out you're
better off for having done it
because otherwise you could paralyze
yourself what if i fail what if i fail
what if i fail that doesn't mean you
completely go
narcissistic and and
land that nothing can ever fail i mean i
really like the
fail faster lean startup kind of
thinking i said let's just try little
experiments and and if they work great
if they don't work that's okay we
learned something and we didn't sort of
stake our entire self-esteem on that one
idea
because i think that's really important
so when i look back i would say yes of
course there are things i mean there are
things about wikipedia that i find weird
today
that you would think sort of 20 years on
we would have solved so if you go on the
talk page of any wikipedia article or
you go to wikipedia you find me you go
to my user talk page you leave a comment
for me
when i go to respond to the comment i
have to type colon colon to indent my
comment or you know colon and then once
we've had a dialogue of like five layers
deep i've gotta actually have colon
colon colon colon colon two and that's
insane like why not have a threaded
discussion system like just
automatically indent i hit reply to your
comment and it goes just like in reddit
and there are some good reasons for it
it's complicated right but it's it's
actually like
that's a vestige of the past that's
there because it's always been there it
actually works for us
it's a weird barrier to entry for new
people because people come in and
they're like i want to respond in this
thread and i clicked edit and there's
all this weird colon stuff i don't
really
get it whereas in other places you just
would hit reply to the comment you want
to budget the problem is once you try to
reform something like that you suddenly
realize
there's a huge amount of
history and culture and the way we do
things that actually is tied up in that
software affordance
what i mean by that is
at wikipedia if you leave a comment
like if you you and i are in a
discussion and you comment something to
me and i go to reply and i notice that
you've misspelled a word clearly just a
typo nothing weird but i'm like actually
that words myself i can correct your
typo
and hit save just as a part of my edit
and suddenly our conversation just reads
much better because your typo got fixed
and
people can see that i did that so like
if i change your comment to be the
opposite of what you said people go
crazy but that kind of little thing
which seems kind of silly it actually is
part of the whole process or if somebody
comes onto my talk page and they're like
insulting and rude and somebody else is
like that's not helpful at all anybody
literally anybody can just come and
delete that comment because it's just a
wiki page and again everyone could see
that they deleted it so if they're
called out on it there's a history and
you can track it and you can go oh this
person deleted a comment why did they do
that and then you look at it you're like
oh
actually thanks for deleting that that
person was just being a racist jerk and
that's not really
useful so we got rid of it so all that
kind of stuff so then you think about
okay well let's build a threaded comment
system where anybody can edit anything
it's actually quite hard it's one of the
things that at my pilot project of wt
social that we're doing
is
we've got comments it's like can other
people hide your comment can they edit
your comment
and you know that's the kind of thing
that we're experimenting with and it's
it's hard actually it's super hard and
it's it's also
such a superpower maybe it's a practiced
skill it's probably both actually
of
really and this term is used a lot
user-centric design but putting yourself
in the decision tree of someone who is
trying to do something it seems so
obvious
obviously useful but it is not always
obviously done if that makes sense yeah
and actually one of the things i find
that it actually does get done and i
think slightly overdone
in
let's put myself in the shoes of
a bad actor
so what could a bad person do
and i feel that if you over design for
what a bad person could do then you fail
to think about the design for perfectly
nice people
so you could say
yeah actually a bad person could be
really irritating by going around
wikipedia changing people's comments to
say the opposite of what they were gonna
say so then if your natural response is
okay let's just not let people do that
then you also cut out all the health
that is possible if you leave people
open to do that i have this analogy to i
call it the steak knives analogy which
is imagine you're designing a restaurant
and you think okay in my restaurant i'm
going to serve steak because i like
steak and i'm going to give everybody
steak knives and
one thing we know about people with
knives is they might stab each other
so therefore i'm gonna build a cage
around every table so that no one can
stab each other
uh
and yeah when you hear this you laugh
because you're like oh that's hilarious
because like yeah but then what do we do
about it actually that is true people
could stub each other and what we do is
we we recognize that it's really rare
for one thing that we actually don't
want to live in a society where we live
in cages because some people might be
crazy we have various institutions as a
society to deal with the problem so for
example if somebody does start stabbing
people in a restaurant usually
some brave
soul hopefully young and strong will
tackle the person stop the violence
immediately and and we would call that a
hero we think that's a great thing to do
in society is to
do what's necessary to prevent damage in
a tragedy and then we've got the
ambulance that comes to hopefully fix
things and we've got the police to take
the bad person to jail
and
none of those things are perfect people
sometimes will get stabbed and it is a
tragedy and there is no recovering from
it and that's terrible but we still say
you know what we don't want to live in
cages we wouldn't think let's redesign
everything so that we're in a cage
and so i kind of feel this way about
when i think about things like
the way social networks are designed i
often think why can't i go and edit
somebody else's comment well
the reason is because they're thinking
well bad people will do it and so now no
one can do it but actually maybe if you
have the right kind of systems and
processes and transparency in place it
could be a great thing maybe not but you
know i just think too often if you
design for the worst people then you're
you're failing to design for good people
it makes a lot of sense this steak knife
metaphor drives the point home and
i have just a few questions i want to
move shortly to current projects and how
you think about current projects
but i have a few broader questions first
the first is what motivates great
contributors
and how do you keep them happy or what
are the things that keep them happy
that's a great question is is exactly
what we think about a lot what the
wikimedia foundation thinks about a lot
which is what we call community health
are people having fun are they doing
good work are they enjoying doing good
work do they feel supported are they
supported and all of those things so a
great wikipedian in my view
is someone who
really takes seriously the values and
ideas of wikipedia like neutrality for
example quality for example
reliable sources
and they take all those things more
important than any particular say
political opinion they might have
so
as i consider myself a good wikipedian i
would not for example edit the entry on
donald trump
because
he makes me crazy
and i wouldn't be able to be neutral i
would go in and i would probably just
my blind rage at this ridiculous person
would make it really hard for me to be a
good wikipedian in that area so i just
don't go there
and i think a lot of good wikipedians
are like that it's like okay here's
something i really am passionate about
but i know
i can't really be neutral about it so i
really should just stay away from it and
i think that's a great quality
and also just this idea of
kindness and thoughtfulness to say i go
into this debate it's gotten a little
rough and tumble
but what can i bring to this debate that
will actually help other people be calm
help this be productive maybe i can find
a compromise between different people
who have different perspectives and i
think those are really great people to
have in wikipedia
systematically are there things that you
can do with respect to the fostering of
those values or
the cultivation of the engagement of the
people who have those values what are
some of the
organizational decisions so one of the
things that we've done recently i think
is a really fantastic thing is we've
introduced
a new universal code of conduct which is
really
came
from the community a huge consultative
process within the community to really
get the wording exactly right
and the idea is to say look we have a
code of conduct which is really about
all these values it's about being
inclusive being open being friendly
being a safe space not to use a buzzword
but
that's been a fantastic thing and it
really is about saying look we know
these values work for wikipedia they
make wikipedia better and we also know
that sometimes it's quite hard to
enforce them because
of a variety of factors so
in terms of
bad behavior so bad behavior at
wikipedia
if you come to wikipedia and you just
start
insulting people and being racist and
being a real jerk that is so easy to
deal with like the community will just
boot you out immediately you'll get
blocked that's that end of story it's
really not that complicated there's no
internal community drama about it it is
what it is
the harder ones are
what about a contributor who's like
super productive in writing in some area
and they're also
quite rude and kind of jerky to other
people maybe they're just on the
borderline of the sort of thing that
would get them blocked but they're just
like basically a negative energy in the
space and they're causing a lot of
trouble
that's the ones that the community
really does struggle with i think any
system would struggle with because it's
like we appreciate the work that you're
doing but you're basically probably
driving off more good work than you are
able to contribute yourself by being a
jerk all the time
and that is the kind of thing that the
universal code of conduct is really
meant to sort of help us step up and say
you know what actually
the fact that you've written 35 great
entries about some of your topic does
not excuse you insulting people in the
story it's just not okay and we will
find someone else to write those 35
things because
it's not necessary to be a jerk in the
community no matter what we do those are
very human decisions they're very
you know there is no simple formula one
of the things we've never done in
wikipedia never would do is have
points or likes or that sort of thing
because it's just inhuman really it's
like
human personalities are so rich and so
varied
that really like the best thing is like
the kind of great wikipedian in my mind
is the person who's able to go in and
kind of
hold hands with that contributor who's
doing great work by being difficult and
kind of coach them into being nicer as a
human being you know it's like hey you
don't have to go around with chip on
your shoulder all the time i'm going to
help you deal with the problems that
you're trying to address but you should
probably stop yelling at people and and
we have great people in the community
who are good at that and that's really
kind of amazing i'd like to revisit this
pathological optimism
[Music]
because i mean the term pathological is
is funny right
and i mean if we go to pathos right now
this kind of feeling or in some cases
suffering but let's go with the feeling
i would like to feel more optimism
and not to say that i'm eeyore or
anything like that but
if i could turn the dial a few clicks
for a general higher state of optimism
i feel like i would be better for it is
that something that just
came hardwired in you out of the box is
it something that you've
developed
how would you answer that
i would say it's just kind of a deeply
ingrained
part of my personality but i also think
i do cultivate it
because
you know like anybody i i think you can
work yourself into
a funk it's not hard to do
and you can
therefore
become more pessimistic than you should
it's not hard for people to do that and
i think if you have a certain set of
practices around
saying no actually i'm going to remember
count my blessings
i'm going to look for the fun bit of
this and the opportunity and and what
can i change
and sometimes
what happens to people and this is
actually where if we go back to things
like your money or your life there are a
lot of people who are stuck in jobs they
don't like
but they don't feel that they can leave
because they've got this mortgage and
car payment
and one of the things that book does is
say
okay why do you have that mortgage in
car payment what if you drove a crappy
car
instead of the expensive car what does
that mean why would you do that to
yourself if it's causing you to be stuck
in a job that you hate obviously that's
easier for some people in some
circumstances than others but it is a
common thing that people get themselves
in a situation where they're living a
lifestyle that's
too expensive for what they're earning
and therefore
they're unhappy and they don't see a way
out and one way out is to go you know
what you're valuing the wrong things
so that's about reflecting and saying
you know what actually
you know what the greatest thing in the
world is the greatest thing in the world
is
and you said you're trying to sell
yourself on having kids the greatest
thing in the world is going out with
your kids and look at here in the uk
they call them wood lice which sounds
disgusting we call them goldy pulleys in
the south which is much nicer but you go
out and you find some roly-polies right
and you look under a rock and you get
the roly-polies and you you roll them
you know you get them to roll and you
put them on a twig that's great stuff
that's what life is it's absolutely free
and
if you remember that sort of thing as a
practice not just hopefully but just
actually go you know what i'm in a funk
about work but you know what there's
more important things in life let's go
do that then it turns out
if you can turn your your head around in
that way then actually when you get back
to the work problem you're more likely
to have a creative solution to the to
the situation whatever that might mean
what are some of your practices
maybe they are just consistent and in
which case they're kind of preemptively
avoiding funk tendencies or when you get
into a funk are there particular
practices you should count your
blessings for instance how does that it
doesn't have to be this example but if
it were something like that how might it
manifest in your life what is it what
does it look like
i don't know it's so ingrained and it's
not like a morning journaling practice
yeah i don't i don't you know it's just
sort of like yeah just kind of pull
myself together but i don't want to be
too glib i mean people do struggle with
genuine problems of of depression
uh people are in genuinely very hard
circumstances so it's quite easy from
where i sit to go yeah just cheer
yourself up and everything's gonna be
great and i know that's not right which
is why i call it pathological but i do
think there's something too
if you can find that positive side then
you do have a better chance of working
out whatever the actual problem is
right well you also i mean speaking of
someone who is a history of
and this this goes
back
hundreds and i'm sure thousands of years
in my family line just given the
software but
history of depressive episodes twice a
year probably extended episodes up until
maybe seven or eight years ago it's
difficult to see solutions
with that shroud of mist
over your perceptive faculties if that
makes sense like you see problems but
you don't see solutions and that in and
of itself is a meta problem right yeah
yeah no it is it is and and i like to
say i don't want to be glib about
these are real issues they're hard
issues for
lots of people and so it's it's really
if you're in the midst of a depressive
episode literally the last thing you
need is for me to ring you on the phone
and go hey just look on the bright side
man you know like come on [ __ ] like
are you kidding me
everything sucks right now and i didn't
really need this you know that's not
really what i mean but i do think there
are things you know sort of remember the
good things you know at the dark moments
can be can be quite helpful
what are you working on right now what
is it that you're you're directing your
time and energies to
so i spend a lot of time on wt social
sort of design and so on got a very
small team though so the software
progress is very slow i deliberately
chose not to raise money at the outset
because i i felt if i did
if i'm trying to reinvent social
networking if i raise money early which
i could do because of my position
i would suddenly be on a certain kind of
vc driven treadmill to get to a certain
place and to do this and that the other
and i just didn't want to i wanted to
have complete creative freedom to really
kind of think and innovate and about
some quite hard problems so i spent a
fair amount of time working on that but
i also
during lockdown
so at the beginning of lockdown i would
say when when we first
last march here is when everything went
into complete shutdown
it was an amazing
weird time you know suddenly
from
traveling all over the world giving
speeches i'm like here at home and the
kids are here and and all that and
basically
for the first couple of months i was
like oh i'll just carry on i always work
from home i work remote it's no big deal
and then i'm like actually this is weird
because i i can answer more emails but
as anybody who
i mean i'm sure you're this way in fact
i have a feeling i remember there's
something you wrote about email but like
literally with email the problem with
email is the more email you answer the
more email you get you know like there's
no such thing as finishing your email
like
you know it's just like forget it you're
never going to finish your email because
you if you email 100 people a day
they're all going to freaking email you
back tomorrow and then 20 more people so
you know it's kind of hopeless so then i
realized like this is not productive
this is not it and i thought you know
what i actually what am i going to do
with myself i don't know i mean i'm
normally spending a huge amount of time
preparing for speeches researching the
client who i'm speaking for so i can
customize to what they're interested in
and i travel and i do my speech i do
press interviews and all that and
suddenly that's all gone completely gone
along with by the way my income so
that's a little bit annoying and i just
thought you know what i love programming
i love coding never get a chance to do
it so i basically just started doing
online programming classes and just like
i want to get my free up my skills
start doing things started really
learning a lot of interesting things got
very interested in
webrtc so video on web and then with my
friends and family we started doing a
weekly pub quiz here and now i also do
it with my mom and dad and my family in
america
and basically it's just like you know
you could get on once a week and and
somebody has created a quiz and you do
the quiz and everybody jokes around and
that's it and i thought well this is
great but it's on zoom it's not really
that great you know zoom is great it's
just a business video conferencing tool
so i created a new website which is
called quiz night beyond where it's just
like a fun website so it's all about
quizzes you can go in and create quizzes
and you can invite people you can
schedule just like you schedule a zoom
meeting and everybody meets and in the
middle is the quiz and everybody's doing
it together and there's the videos and
it's all about teasing your friends and
joking around and that is going to
launch well i mean hopefully by the time
this podcast is out it will have
launched but it's
quiznitebeyond.com and i'm really
enjoying it it's like
it's it's one of these things it's like
that entrepreneurial itch
of like here's something that i want to
do which is do quizzes with my family
during lockdown so that we get a chance
to to see people let me in a second i'm
going to side rant about social
networking
and yet it doesn't quite work the way i
would like it to and now i see a way to
solve that problem and like tick and i'm
going to do it is it going to be
commercial success i hope so
is it not i don't care because it's
something i want to exist so i'm making
it so that i can use it and if everybody
else likes it that's great too and then
my side rant
on this front and part of what inspires
me the whole concept of wt social is
around
the social networking is really broken
it's not healthy jimmy what does the wt
stand for a wiki tribune it's basically
a pivot wiki tribune was kind of
thinking about how to get people
involved in news and how to collaborate
on news
and as we were doing that i learned a
lot but i came to realize the real
problem with news is not what's going on
in journalism it's what's going on in
the wider ecosystem where they live
it's that the advertising only social
media really rewards clickbait headlines
full stop and so
clickbait headlines clickbait content
low quality stuff goes viral
and it's not conducive to serious
hard-hitting journalism which also can
go viral but it's very expensive so with
wt social i just really am in this
process of thinking what's what's wrong
what's wrong with social networking
what's unhealthy here
and i suddenly realized
as we started doing the weekly quiz
my family is kind of dispersed my mom
and dad live in alabama my sister lives
in seattle brothers in north carolina
we're kind of dispersed
and so whatever we talk we we have phone
calls from time to time we've got a
family whatsapp group we've got the kids
only whatsapp group where we talk about
you know what's going on with mom and
dad and how can we help and that sort of
thing
and
basically what i realized is by seeing
them all once a week and we're just
doing a quiz it's just a fun thing to do
and there's mom and there's my sisters
and there's you know i have the one
sister who i had kind of grown apart
from not not no serious break or
anything but just you know we weren't
talking that much for a long time
suddenly i see them every week and we're
joking around and we're laughing we're
laughing about stuff when we were kids
and it's really human
and i realized you know like
what is social networking what are we
when we think about social uses of
computers
so much better so much healthier than
for example something that's completely
innocuous but like
if i click like on a picture of my
sister's dog on instagram
are we kidding ourselves that that's
social that is the most limited form of
human engagement it's just like i like
your picture of your dog
okay so right that's not that's not a
conversation right that's not actually
joking around it's not talking about the
family it's not teasing each other about
a quiz question you know like real human
interaction
so for me that's that's really
interesting and so that's kind of what
i'm focusing on is like okay how do we
really reimagine like from the ground up
what does it mean to use computers in a
social way i think we've got this really
interesting opportunity to do that
around video
simply because because of lockdown like
everybody's gotten used to doing zoom
calls right it's it's a thing and
obviously we'll stop doing as much of
that once we can go back and meet in a
bar or whatever but you know there are
certainly old friends who i wouldn't
meet in a bar necessarily around london
because
they live all over the world who i'm
like oh now it wouldn't be that weird to
go oh let's get a bunch of people
together and go on zoom together like
why not it's kind of fun well count me
in i
love this idea in part because zoom
calls and video conferencing without
some type of context can work
but it can also be
very
challenging so having an activity 100
is key at least for me
yeah ori my co-founder at wiki tribune
put it this way she's like
when you go
to your extended family for a holiday
dinner one of the reasons we have that
huge dinner is to give everybody
something to do
right
even if you really love your family it's
like suddenly you you're popped in front
of your mom dad brothers sisters cousins
and you're sitting in a room staring at
each other it could be quite awkward but
instead we've got these rituals we've
got something to do we've got
who's going to make the mashed potatoes
and and then we go and we sit together
and you know people have their
traditions christmas traditions and that
sort of thing and this is kind of that
it's like okay
yeah if you're going to get your whole
family together once a week for a call
and you've got nothing to do
it's going to be weird quite often could
be very awkward but you know it's like
let's do an activity together it's it's
a conversation starter it's kind of a
icebreaker
i want to also emphasize what i think is
perhaps sometimes missed not always it
gets discussed but the genius of
scratching your own itch in the sense
that there are many companies that
people might assume have
these
10-year 20-year master plans that have
been executed to perfection with all of
these
strategies and tactics and plans for
team and flywheels and so on but there
are
certainly i would say just as many
examples maybe more examples of
companies that started as products to
scratch the itch of one or two people
and
if you design in that way if you build
in that way you have at least a
guaranteed market of one right yeah
which is far less speculative
than uh
than a lot of what goes on so i'm
excited to see where it goes yeah i
think that's right actually what i think
is
is interesting about it really is
that when you think about what can be
successful so if you're an entrepreneur
and you want to go into business i
always tell
young entrepreneurs if you just look
around and you do some analysis and you
pick the thing you think is going to
make the most money but it's kind of
boring to you
chances are you're not going to make
that much money because it's boring to
you it's not something you find is a
passion in and of itself you're just
there to try to take off some boxes and
make some money
you might think that's a clever thing
you're like well i it's boring but i'm
going to only do it for five years i'm
going to sell out for a ton of money
it's like no you're probably going to do
it for two years and you're going to
hate every minute of it you're not going
to be good at it because you hate it
versus if you scratch your own itch
you're like oh here's the thing if this
existed i think that would be cool i
think it'd be interesting by the way it
doesn't have to be a consumer product it
could be b2b just anything that you come
up with that you're like wow this should
exist and i think it would be cool then
if you've built it you can be proud that
you built it and if there's some weird
reason why it just didn't work out as a
business yeah fine no big deal
jimmy
it's so nice to reconnect and spend time
together
and i have one
one last question one or two last
questions and this one sometimes goes
nowhere fast and i'll take full blame
for i'll take full blame for it if it if
that ends up being the case but
if you could put anything on a
billboard metaphorically speaking to get
a message a quote a question an image
anything out to billions of people
what would you put on that billboard or
what might you put on that billboard
well i mean i think
the the thing that immediately pops to
my mind is is my original vision
statement for wikipedia which is imagine
a world in which every single person on
the planet is given free access to the
sum of all human knowledge
because to me that is still like
wow that's so exciting right just to
think every single person on the planet
completely for free has access to the
sum of all human knowledge you can do
anything then you can learn you can grow
you can heal you can cure
you know it's amazing to think about
what are all the implications of that
statement and so i i just think
the more people who
are thinking that way obviously for
wikipedia but it's not about wikipedia's
organization but it's just like wow what
can we do to make sure that education
and knowledge are universally accessible
because you know we got a lot of
problems on this planet we need as many
smart educated people to figure them out
as we possibly can so let's make sure
everybody has the ability to join in
that intellectual project here here well
jimmy people can find quiz night beyond
quiznitebeon.com
it's always fun to connect it's been a
little while yeah
and
and i really appreciate you taking the
time today from so far away although so
close via voice
is there anything else you would like to
add any closing comments uh requests of
the audience anything at all before we
bring this to a close
no no it's good i mean i hope people
will check out quiz night beyond and uh
come and visit me on wt.social and you
know say hi on twitter and try not to be
a troll on the internet and that's all
good
that is a good that is a good party
message to leave
embedded in the minds of everyone
listening when in doubt don't be a troll
on the internet it is not that positive
yeah jimmy thank you so much for the
time really enjoyed the conversation and
to everybody listening we will put links
to
all resources all websites everything
that popped up in the show notes as per
usual at team.blog4slashpodcast
and until next time thanks for tuning in
hey guys this is tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one
this is five bullet friday do you want
to get a short email from me would you
enjoy getting a short email from me
every friday that provides a little more
soul of fun for the weekend and five
bullet friday is a very short email
where i share the coolest things i've
found or that i've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that i've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that i've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as i do
it could include favorite articles that
i've read and that i've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to four
hourworkweek.com that's
4hourworkweek.com all spelled out and
just drop in your email and you will get
the very next one and if you sign up i
hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by you
need a budget what is you need a budget
you need a budget is a cult favorite
budgeting app for a reason
it works and i'm going to come back to
that cult favorite because oh my god
they really do have a cult following the
app and it's simple for rule method will
change the way you think about your
money and help you gain total control so
you can plan for the things you need and
get the things you want without guilt or
stress
to give you an idea on the cult favorite
side to date they know of at least seven
customers who have customized their
license plates to mark the occasion of
purchasing a new car in cash
and these fans do this by including ynab
you need a budget on their license place
so people love this app you need a
budget that has helped millions of
people transform their finances save
their marriages and live life on their
own terms i even asked pete adney who's
been on the podcast best known as mr
money mustache super popular episode
what he thought and he's a big fan of
the founder and what they're doing so it
was check check check green light green
light green light across the board you
need a budget's simple four rule method
will actually teach you how to manage
your money you will learn a new way of
thinking new habits and new behaviors
that will help you get out of debt break
the paycheck to paycheck cycle and build
wealth faster the you need a budget team
is committed to your success they offer
free live classes every day of the week
video courses boot camps challenges and
active fan groups in every corner of the
internet there's something for everyone
if you want to learn they can teach you
that you need a budget team believes
that no one can tell you what your money
should do only you can decide what
matters most to you your budget is
simply a tool to help you stay focused
on your true priorities reach your goals
and live a life of your design on
average new budgeters save more than six
hundred dollars by month two and six
thousand dollars in their first year so
try the app free for 34 days no credit
card required at you need a budget dot
com slash tim spelled as you would
expect in proper english try
you need a budget free for 34 days no
credit card required at you need a
budget dot com slash tim and just to
explain 34 days that's because most
people reconcile at the end of the month
or 38 period so having a couple of days
of cushion helps folks out so 34 days
with no credit card required at you need
a budget dot com slash
this podcast episode is brought to you
by helix sleep
sleep is super important to me in the
last few years i've come to conclude it
is the end-all be-all that all good
things
good mood good performance good
everything seemed to stem from good
sleep so i've tried a lot to optimize
and i've tried pills and potions all
sorts of different mattresses you name
it and for the last few years i've been
sleeping on a helix midnight luxe
mattress i also have one in the guest
bedroom and feedback from friends has
always been fantastic it's something
that they comment on helix sleep has a
quiz takes about two minutes to complete
that matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you with helix there's a specific
mattress for each and every body that is
your body also your taste so let's say
you sleep on your side and like a super
soft bed no problem or if you're a back
sleeper who likes a mattress that's as
firm as a rock they've got a mattress
for you too helix was selected as the
number one best overall mattress pick of
2020 by gq magazine wired apartment
therapy and many others just go to helix
sleep.com
tim take their two-minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life they have a 10-year
warranty you get to try it out for 100
nights risk-free they'll even pick it up
from you if you don't love it and now my
dear listeners helix is offering up to
hundred dollars off of all mattress
orders and two free pillows at
helixsleep.com
tim these are not cheap pillows either
so getting two for free is an upgraded
deal so that's up to 200 off and two
free pillows at helixsleep.com
tim that's helix h-e-l-i-x
sleep.com
tim for up to 200 off
so
check it out one more time helix
h-e-l-i-x sleep.com
time
[Applause]